Working with cones of yarn that are
slippery presents some challenges.
The yarn can slip down into a pool on
the floor and then catch beneath the cone
caught like this, it can also break and
jam and snag your knitting and cause all
sorts of frustration when knitting.
This yarn can slip out of the hooks and
jump up and a loop over the gate pegs.
Here are some tips for working with
slippery yarn to help keep the yarn on the
cone, place it in a plastic bag, and
scrunch that bag down so the plastic is
bunched up around the bottom.
This will help keep the yarn from
pooling and catching underneath the cone.
You can use yarn bras.
Nylon stockings or even compression
bandages to keep the slippery yarn in
place.
Just remember that anything that
constricts the yarn coming off the cone
can impact your gauge.
So swatch using the same method.
If you find your slippery yarn or any yarn
for that matter, if it tends to jump off
the needles and mis-forms stitches or
it gets caught around the gate pegs, you
might want to try adding
more weight to your knitting.
The key here is to use even
weight across the work.
Try using a ribber cast on comb.
Using waste yarn, pull out every
other needle and knit across.
Now insert the iubber
cast on comb in the loops.
You'll see I've pushed that cast on comb
back so the teeth come out in front of the
gate pegs and I can slip the wire through.
You'll also notice that I've marked the
center tooth of the comb with a bright
nail Polish.
This makes it easier to align that
comb to this center of the work.
Again, our goal here is to add even
weight all the way across the work.
After you've inserted the wire, you
carefully just knit one row and pull down
on that cast on comb.
Put all your needles into work and
continue to knit a few rows with waste
yarn.
Hang some weights on the cast on comb, and
you might need to experiment a little bit,
not too much weight, but enough weight
so the stitches will form properly.
Cast on with your main
yarn and knit your garment.
You'll find with this method that the
stitches are going to behave a little
better, even with slippery yarn.
And don't forget for accurate gauge
measurement, you need to swatch using this
method as well.
Don't let slippery yarn
get the best of you.
Thank you for watching.
Please consider a subscription to Knit
it Now subscribers have full access to
hundreds of tutorials on a wide
range of topics and all skill levels.
Happy knitting.